failure is a stepping stone to success
fail you'll lead to success failure
failure is a part of a learning process
success is moving from one failure to
the next to get past your failure you've
got to go through the failure success is
merely the hangover of failure you
should seek failures learn from those
mistakes and get smarter hello belief
nation my name is Evan Carmichael my one
word is believe and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to solve all the
major problems of the world so to help
you on your journey today we're going to
learn how you can turn failure into
success and as always guys if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired as well and when you write
it down it's much more likely to stick
for yourself to enjoy
[Music]
failure is part of life I mean the
difference for me though is I'm a
failure is a stepping stone to success
it's a speed bump I know I'm going to
fail but it's not failure if you learn
something and so gosh I've made so many
mistakes I've screwed so many things up
but every time I do it just becomes it
becomes a way for me to explain to
someone else what it takes you know it's
like here's what I've done I think I
have the ability to influence people
because I talk about my failures I talk
about all the things that mess me up but
I show people that didn't let it stop me
and you only to stop you and I think I
think that's really a secret matter and
if everything you touch was successful
but I got to relate to people as well
you'll be right and also be total bull
and everyone know it's bulls and also
you'd be bored silly I mean think about
it if you just said I want this to
happen I want this to happen you know
people don't value it they don't fight
for you know it looks like you see kids
sometimes in it you know your parents
will say you're not going to value this
if you don't work for it and your kid
going oh well you just give it to me but
it's true you know but things we've
worked the hardest for we value the most
so I think you know the purpose of the
goal is not getting it anyway the
purpose of goal you know is what who you
become when you become is going to make
you happier kind of make you sad so I'm
not looking for an effortless approach
there's no such thing and you constantly
remind yourself after every defeat after
every setback every time you get knocked
down I've got a saying it's life knocks
you down try and land on your back
because if you can look up you can get
up see a lot of people because of
failure they stop they stop believing
let me share something with you you will
fail your way to success yes eight out
of ten millionaires have been
financially bankrupt you will fail your
way to success it doesn't matter how
many times you fail it doesn't matter
how many times people tell you that you
can't do it it doesn't matter if you
don't have a dime in the Bakke you will
fail your way to success I've learned
more from failure than success
and it can be paralyzing this um failure
and the fear of it my first time I made
was album core reasonable doubt which in
the small circles was considered the
album like in classic album like the
album for that generation in the voice
of you know people that were going
through similar situations but it didn't
sell massive numbers worldwide right it
was still very niche in my second album
because of you know reasonable doubt and
its lack of commercial success you know
I try to make these records that were
bigger and will be more popular which
was a failure going for that success
really messed up that project and you
know said it back home
it was the huge learning lesson for me
that if I was going to be successful I
had to be successful with myself I
couldn't be successful doing what other
people were doing I had to do what I
believed in and what help real to me it
felt true to me failure is a part of a
learning process right what's the risk
of failure what you'll be embarrassed or
risk of how do you distinguish failure
from learning in your whole life you
know failure implies that it stopped
that the game stops alright if it's part
of a you're failing and then you learn
then that learning is part of the moving
forward right so that is what the
process is like fail learn move forward
and constantly do that because you're
cutting edge you're going where people
haven't been before in inventiveness if
you say I'm a fraud they'll figure me
out I'll never be able to do it again
that's an artist star pause this is
you're an artist you're thinking like
that you're on the right track because
they all feel that so you there's always
some success that can come out even out
of your failure the fact might be your
biggest successes will come directly
from your failures you should almost
take that Winston Churchill's quote as
my favourite success is moving from one
failure to the next with great
enthusiasm you should be very
enthusiastic about your failures because
you're going to learn something you're
going to go that way whenever when I was
going
that way and you're going to stumble but
you're also going to stumble upon
something that no one ever thought of so
you know you just keep going and keep
going and you're going to fail and then
rise up and fail again and that's the
journey up and down man
you don't make excuses for the failure
you grieve it you feel the pain you
don't brush it off you don't downplay it
you feel the pain and you don't rush to
feel better now listen this is a
principle of life I'm about to tell you
to get past it you got to go through it
that's true in so many areas but it's
particularly true with failure to get
past your failure that failure in your
you got to go through it you can't go
around your failure you can't go over
your failure you can't go under your
failure you can't ignore your failure
you need to grieve the failure you need
to feel the pain now we don't like
feeling bad but grief is a good thing
grief is the way we get through the
failure and grief is the way we learn
the lessons so often we want to just
when we fail we want to just forget it
push it aside stuff our emotions and
then immediately go to the next thing
when you stuff your emotions when you
swallow your emotions your stomach keeps
score it's kind of like what if you took
a can of coke and you shook it up for a
long time and then you put it in the
freezer what's going to happen to it
it's going to explode eventually it's
going to come out sideways and this
happens in your life when you don't deal
with your emotions properly this is why
sometimes six months after failure a
marriage falls apart are six months
after somebody gets laid off work
there's another problem there's a
physical health problem things like that
because you've shaken up the can and
you've got all these emotions feeling
inside of shame and regret and fear and
and and insecurity and all the things
that come with failure and you're not
dealing with them and so you shake it up
and so we're just going to put this in a
refrigerator try to forget about and
we're going to freeze it and it's going
to explode and it's going to come out
sideways in an affair or in wrong
behavior or an impulsivity or an
addiction or all kind
of other things I have seen this
thousands of times in people's lives
you don't minimize it you don't rush to
feel better to get past your failure
you've got to go through the failure you
know and my mentality is like I have a I
don't lose mentality and that's what any
dance not just like say a sporting event
or whatever rest is life right
because life is non-stop tests you know
what I mean and we're always being put
to test there's always challenges
obstacles etc and I literally don't
accept any of that as a impediment as a
negative it's like good this is going to
make me stronger I want to learn
something from her see I think the best
advice that I could give you on success
is to know that success is merely the
hangover of failure and that failure is
an essential ingredient in creating a
learning atmosphere for you so that you
can accrue those learnings those small
incremental steps of failure and collect
enough learning so that you can arrive
at success right I think we're taught in
the system that failure is something
that you should be ashamed of failure is
for the dumb kids because you can f you
get a D right you're not competent you
didn't comply you didn't create the
evidence of your worthiness but I can
tell you is someone who's successful
right both financially and from a wealth
creation point of view but more
importantly a wealth that matters that
success doesn't look like an a-plus it
doesn't look like a hundred and ten and
extra credit and failure isn't as simple
as an F and it's not always Kelly's like
failure could be very gray right and
being able to discern what you might
arrive at an event or in your life where
you think that wow I've succeeded and
you're getting the affirmation from all
these outside of forces but if it's not
aligned authentically with to whom which
you are it could very much feel like
failure you're going to fail it's okay
okay you're going to fail and I'm not
talking about the test it's one thing
talking about to your knees your skin
bloody fail and that's okay because you
know what you know down deep inside all
of you that's how you learn you need to
be motivated by failure how'd you learn
how to walk you crawled then you fell
down busted your tooth got some blood in
your mouth get up and you walk right
self directed you should seek failures
see if you're playing it safe you're not
going to win if you're playing it safe
like that all say you know you're
talking you're a little girl better to
be safe than sorry well that's a bunch
of crap it's not better be safe than
sorry
it's by trying things that you figure
out how far you can go you got to get
outside the box like it's reported
Edison tried 3000 ways before he built
the incandescent light he made he fit
hidden Dale 3,000 times he said there
was 3,000 different steps to building a
light bulb well there's different steps
to get to where you're going and I
really do treat winning and losing
exactly the same I do not let it upset
me do you think that's a big part of why
you're so successful well it's part of
why I enjoy it yeah I think it is
because I'll try anything like if if I'm
into an idea the idea of losing never
enters my mind see I have worked with
Giants I had the good fortune of working
with Sir Edmund Hillary he was the first
man to stand on top of the world and I
worked with him on three different
occasions and the only difference in ed
Hillary and Bob Proctor is in his his
size now he's gone now but he was a big
man he shook hands with me his hand wrap
right around mine I felt like Oh dwarf
you know and he talked into him like it
never entered his mind he wouldn't get
to the top
Mountain but he failed in 1951 he failed
in 1952
it wasn't until 1953 that he got to the
top of the month no people had died for
centuries trying to do that he said I
knew if I could see it in here I could
hold it out here still a man wrote that
in the book he can seat her head you can
hold it your hand and that's right and
if you're not prepared to lose you're
never gonna win because you always paint
it safe and there's no there's no reward
man I'm a woman in business or you and
it's great because they're different
personalities successful be yourself
take care of business be yourself or
yeah and out there but it can be bumpy
along the way any regrets or mistakes
that you feel you've kind of hit through
the years well you know I share certain
bumps that I've had in the book I think
that you know I don't like to look back
there are no mistakes really everything
is a learning lesson and everything
helps you to do better so I talked about
some of the mistakes that I made and it
just helps you to get further along
learn from those mistakes and get
smarter thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what was your biggest takeaway from
this video what are you going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
or to your business leave it down the
comments below I'm super curious to find
out I also want to give a quick shout
out to Wesley lavender from fully
optimized org Wesley thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word it really really means a lot to
me and I hope you're enjoying the read
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon